actor Jeremy Pope is known for the
Broadway show choir boy and I saw him in
the Broadway show The Temptations Ain't
Too Proud to Beg and the Netflix series
Hollywood now he's taking on his first
lead role thank you very much in a movie
the movie is called the inspection
Jeremy Pope plays French a queer man who
was kicked out of his house by his very
homophobic mother that was Gabrielle
Union he joins the Marines before the
repeal of don't ask don't tell in the
scene he confides to his drill
instructor about why he wants to be a
marine despite the Relentless hazing
because of his sexuality
I've been raising myself since I was 16.
my mom
she won't even talk to me
most of my friends are dead or in jail
streets was gonna kill me no matter what
so
if I die in this uniform
I'm a hero
hero yep Jeremy Pope joins us in the
studio in the living room we call it
Jeremy it's really good to see you again
good to see you this movie to me was
very tough to watch I mean the The
Hazing scenes the brutality of it the
the way that he was treated by his
mother Gabrielle Union was just tough on
many levels to watch what was it like
for you to make it did it affect you
yeah it did it was also tough to make
yeah it was a very personal piece our
director Elegance Bratton is based off
of his story true story his life so I
knew coming into this I'd have to make a
lot of emotional space it would be a
very emotionally demanding role but also
a physically demanding role we shot it
in 19 days 19 days Jackson Mississippi
and 117 degree weather
um but it it you know I'm very grateful
for the project it felt like a job of
service did it how so I say that because
it's an indie film so when you're making
indie films you have to your why has to
be because you care about the art and
what's on the page when I read this
ripped I immediately wanted to protect
Elegance because I knew that by him
being so vulnerable and giving us his
story in this way once you give it away
you can't get it back and I knew as a
black queer individual he needed tribe
and he needed community so I wanted to
be the person the audience met before
they could have anything to say to him
so I'm very proud of our film I'm very
proud of Elegance for being so
vulnerable and honest and putting
himself on the front line and I'm you
know just really excited too it's a
tremendous performance yeah and to be
telling that person's story and they're
right there directing you yeah I mean
that's added pressure If you carry it
off like it's not even there at all it
really is powerful thank you but let's
talk about the physical side of it
because this is 19 days 19 days Jackson
Mississippi yeah that wasn't fake sweat
it was hot out there it was very hot you
know and I again I think I was prepared
for the emotional part but the physical
part you know I think I went into it
kind of like they're gonna you know I'm
an actor so they're gonna show me how to
best acted but there are certain things
you just can't fake and boot camp is one
of those things so we got into that
training 3 A.M they'd wake us up and
we'd be there and I was learning a lot
and putting my body and my mind through
a lot you can write a little note and
say is this really necessary I have a
lot of abilities
kind of give those big eyes to the
people in the room like are y'all
serious somebody gonna hold me down
gonna remind them that I'm an actor yeah
they didn't want to Yeah you mentioned
the words job of service yeah I'm often
curious
um with roles like this how did this
movie serve you what did you take out of
this after you were done right
um this is my lead debut in a film
growing up congratulations thank you I I
didn't grow up seeing openly queer gay
black men being creatives artists actors
I didn't know that was possible or
tangible so to have a film where it's
centered around that narrative and
protecting a man in that space is very
affirming to Jeremy Pope yes I spent so
many years abandoning my blackness and
my queerness trying to conform and be
what I think the industry or the media
needs or wants me to be or or expects me
to be
but I think for my career the moment
that I allowed myself to love on myself
and appreciate the evolved version of
who I am yeah that's when all the things
have happened and people go how did how
did that happen I said I just was
stepping in my truth and that freedom
and I think in that I began to step into
my purpose because you were told coming
out could limit your career yeah it you
know you know I remember all the black
boys and and you know we'd graduate
college being in performing arts and it
was that thing of how much do you tell
how much do you give of yourself and
that was one of those things you don't
say nothing because if you do that's
going to mess with your resources
resources mess with your health
insurance your your opportunity is a
word and when you're not seeing anything
I believe seeing is believing but if
you're not seeing you can't believe it
to be true well can I just say Jeremy we
believe as Tony said it's an outstanding
performance as always we remain cheering
you on yeah and representation matters
it does
thank you Jeremy Pope she was tough in
the movie the inspection is in theaters
right now